today President Trump is delivering on
the pledge that he made the day after
Iran attacked American forces in Iraq
where there will be a series of new
sanctions secretary Newton just
mentioned eight senior Iranian officials
that are responsible for the regime's
violence both at home and abroad
we're striking at the heart of the
Islamic Republic's inner security
apparatus president said we don't want
war we want Iran to behave like a normal
nation the reason that the secretary
treasurer and are here this morning is
to continue this campaign our strategic
effort to get Iran to behave in a way
that doesn't continue their 40 year long
effort to terrorize the world we do
believe that it's likely that that plane
was shot down by an Iranian missile we
are we're gonna let the investigation
play out before we make a final
determination it's important that we get
to the bottom of it
I've been on the phone I was on the
phone with president Solinsky just
before I came here I was on the phone
with my Canadian counterpart they were
working to get their resources on the
ground to conduct that thorough
investigation we'll learn more about
what happened to that aircraft and when
we get the results of that investigation
I am confident we and the world will
take appropriate actions in response the
intelligence community is not flawless
we we get it wrong in this case the
intelligence community got it
fundamentally right even the reflections
we've seen after the effect after effect
after this strike the costume Suleiman
took has demonstrated that we were quite
right there was an imminent attack there
was active plotting and we took an
action that we thought was likely to
create less risk for the American people
and I'm a confident that we did that
you